what's your name spread out
my name
this is the moment four-year-old cleo
was rescued
she disappeared whilst at a campsite
and after 18 days she was found two
miles away from her family home locked
in a house
from worry and disbelief
to sheer relief
their baby girl has finally returned
but what happened to cleo the police
have charged 36 year old terrence
darrell kelly for forcibly taking a
child under the age of 16.
the result of an intense police
operation
a huge number of officers involved in
this task force
more than 140
they
sifted through all manner of information
and the some analysts in perth in
particular brought together a few
different elements of their
investigation
to thank police for their work and to
celebrate the rescue of cleo buildings
in perth were lit blue
and hundreds of miles away in carnarvon
signs welcomed cleo home
she was
i felt very well adjusted considering
and the family were very um
appreciative of everything that had been
done for them for now cleo is back home
safe and sound and was seen laughing and
playing in her back garden
but the work for police has just begun
shimane freeman powell sky news